hmm
[Music]
wow
[Music]
[Music]
ah
hey everybody
hope everyone's doing all right
uh did i have happy holidays uh
thanksgiving was nice uh it always is
it's fairly low-key not that many
um
not that many folks it's the same thing
every year but it's nice it's nice it's
reliable it's calm it's um
multiple bottles of wine
[Music]
oh
that's good water
ah
i like this thank you i shot a video
earlier
um so i'm still kind of done up a little
bit plus i i um
i recolor my hair so i re i refresh the
color
uh
stephen sondheim died last friday yes i
did hear
and uh
he was 91 so it's not exactly
a shock it's not
unexpected but it's still sad
hey jamie hey everybody oh quick
reminder um in case you uh didn't notice
the pinned comment um super chats are
incredibly appreciated i do try and keep
up with the chat as it goes um but i'm
not gonna scroll back so if i miss
something you may have to ask it again
or if you want to use a super chat that
will guarantee that i will see your
question plus
you'll get a heart from me to you
so um let's get into this hanukkah is
happening this week
i have a shirt that says imagine your
phone at 10 and lasting eight nights now
you understand hanukkah
that's brilliant i love that that's
fantastic
i've i have one of my closest friends is
jewish i might have to tell her that
um
if only after drinking that wine you
start a sentence with the word
capitalism would make a great opening
for a video essay
capitalism
so i mean if someone wants to clip that
go right ahead
um
i stole nothing miss wiki wolf that is
my original property it's it's
trademarked
i've been wondering is doctor who more
polarizing lately or do i just have
better access to the fandom now
um
i
it it
is and it isn't because let's be very
honest
throughout the entire history of doctor
who
and therefore the entire history of the
fandom there have been people who did
not like what was currently going on
with doctor who and there have been
people who did so that dynamic is not
new there were people who liked what was
going on with doctor who in the 80s and
there were other people that hated it
there were people who
liked what russell t davis did there are
people who hate it there are people who
liked what moffat did they're people who
hate it they're people who started
liking what moffat did but didn't like
how he ended up there are people who
like gymnast or people who hate what
he's doing i think the difference is
that
um
there is a much stronger sense at
this point
that
fandom's many fandoms have gotten very
bad at simply disagreeing
a
position of opinion has come to
represent much more than that so to use
the current error of doctor who as an
example since this is the first time the
doctor has been a woman that has
led to the perception
not always accurately but the perception
that many of the people who disliked
this era especially if they dislike to
write from the outset were simply
against the doctor being a woman and
don't get me wrong some people were flat
out against that but there became that
assumption
and
on the flip side of that it became a
thing
with some people where if you don't want
to be perceived as being one of those
people kind of generally referred to as
the not my doctor crowd if you don't
want to be associated with them then you
have to be prepared to defend this era
almost regardless of its innate
qualities that is not to say some people
don't enjoy it authentically some of
them do
but i think the degree to which people
are prepared to fight about these
opinions that has gotten worse the
actual polarization of the opinions
themselves is not new i just think the
degree to which people are prepared to
really fight about it that's gotten
worse
because again like i'm always quick to
point out
fans being jerks about it
about phantom in general
uh is not new
it's not new at all
like it predates the internet the
internet makes it much easier for people
who disagree to find the people they
disagree with and antagonize them
but these kinds of disagreements already
existed if you're my age or older you
will remember going into comic book
shops and hearing arguments that sounded
like someone was going to throw a punch
over it over freaking spider-man and
batman so
none of this is new it's just the the
internet has exacerbated the existing
issues
have i heard the theory that the
ravagers are the doctor's original race
which explains why the doctor can change
faces at appearances no
i hadn't heard that one specifically
i've heard so
many fan theories and i don't
i don't seek out fan theory as a general
rule
and i don't put a lot of weight in them
the problem is
a lot of
fan theories sound have i i'm not sure
that one i would consider but a lot of
the fan theories have sounded like the
kind of thing chibnall would do or has
done
so it makes it harder for me to dismiss
them out of hand and i don't like that i
like dismissing fan theory out of hand
it's a comfort zone for me
oh
who would be the best worst or most
disappointing division higher i think
they would be very disappointed if they
tried to recruit the monk
i i think he would not live up to their
expectations at all
but you want to bet the production on
the wicked movie won't fall apart this
time i'm not
actually going to bet anything
because i don't care
i don't care
i'm probably never gonna watch it unless
somebody pays me to i saw it on broadway
i don't need the movie
so
the way i see it either enjoy the show
or don't but never argue with another
fan about what is good or not good or at
the very least if you're going to argue
with a fan do it with agreed upon
terms like i think there's plenty of
room for debate even heated argument
provided you are both coming in with an
understanding and like basically set the
ground debate rules
you know
so uh
i i i don't want to make it sound like
we shouldn't be disagreeing or arguing
or
presenting um contrasting points it is
however a situation where like
all right let me put it this way i've
got a few people in my comments at this
point i won't name names but i've gotta
i've got a few people in my comments at
this point who
tend to agree with me and defend my
positions but i see them like
going through and replying to anybody
who disagreed with me in the comments
saying like don't do that
don't do that
like you're just going out of your way
to find people to argue with duh
michael anderson doyle
dharma
thank you very much for the super chat i
greatly appreciate it
anyone who read the comics journal
letters to the editors section knows
this rancor is not new holy crap yeah
that's really true
oh
new member to the channel train cam
thank you very much i appreciate that
yeah i yeah you want to reach back you
can check out
letters to the editor sections and like
he's i forget where i pointed this out
but i did point out at some point
that
while things like hate mail campaigns
and death threats over creative choices
which
don't do that
don't do that
um don't issue death threats at all
actually
but definitely don't do it over
something like freaking creative choices
my god
anyways
the thing is that back in the day
you had to go out of your way to
find out what the address was to mail it
to
to put together a letter handwritten or
typed
if it's typed you had to print it and
like you need to realize the idea well
everyone's got a printer at home not for
a while we didn't
and then you need to fill out an
envelope you need to mail it you need to
pay for the stamp these aren't massive
prohibitive
barriers to entry but it was more work
so fewer people did it
now people can just
harass you on twitter and it's free and
freaking
easy as someone who isn't that bothered
with the timeless child if what i think
is gonna be revealed regarding vendor
and bell happens that might be the thing
that breaks me i mean like the thing is
people have been calling that one
basically as soon as bell
was introduced
people have been
predicting that one and
god i hope not i've heard a lot of
theories that fall under the category of
oh god i hope not but that that one's
that one's definitely a big one have i
seen the original west side story
um
parts of it
i don't like west side story that much
it's fine there's nothing wrong with it
but i don't particularly like it that
much
counsel pitch a temporary doctor wakes
up having regenerated in their sleep
with dead companions and has to stop it
happening but can't exist if they do
that's an interesting pitch
to be sure
the
major drawback you're going to have
there is if whoever you get to be your
cameo doctor is really good because on
paper that would be the opportunity to
cast somebody who would never agree to a
full series you know to have
helen mirren tilda swinton bill nye
you know somebody somebody who's too big
a name to be the doctor for one story
but even if you don't do that the the
possible downside
is that if you do it really well
fans are gonna start clamoring to see
that doctor again regardless and then it
just becomes one more thing that
jackasses like me
yell that we should be getting back and
it was a waste of potential
bring back omega
what are my thoughts on muppet babies
both the original and the reboot the
only thing i know about the reboot is
the whole thing they did with gonzalo
which i applaud and support
the original i thought it was really
cute i liked it at the time i was i was
at the age where i enjoyed that quite a
bit
ah let's see
um
but you get to make people cry
by ending with them getting to say hello
i'm the doctor i meant look
it's not it is not a bad idea but
unfortunately because the way my brain
you need to realize any idea you pitch
me
even a really good one i am going to my
brain just because of the way it works
is going to look for okay what are the
downsides
because that's just what my brain does
it's part of the reason why i think some
people think i'm actually more negative
than i in fact am like especially when i
see something like a trailer and other
people are just being super hyped about
what they see whereas i can't stop my
brain from going okay that was cool and
all but where are the ways this could
fall on its face and not work that's
just what my freaking brain does man i
can't
i can't help it
best case scenario is that the universe
is restored it gets resuffled reshuffled
so that the timeless child is no longer
true i don't care if they retcon the am
i the only one who doesn't
i swear to god
i swear that i am the only person who
hates the timeless child because i do i
hate that idea i hate that reveal i hate
what it implies and i hate what it does
to the doctor as a character but i don't
want it retconned i just want it ignored
if you retcon it that gives it weight
you're saying that it was worth spending
time
to fix and it's not just ignore it
don't give it the oxygen
to that is involved in
freaking retconning it
and not known as captain buzzkill for
nothing
that's true although i've mostly known
that in the podcast-a-sphere
uh is captain buzz is where i earned the
name captain buzzkill
once you get a credit side you can't
unsee it i had this long before i could
be credibly even sarcastically called a
credit i'm not sure i can i suppose i
can
like
i gotta get more comfortable with some
of the labels for what it is i do
because like this is my job
i feel like it's an overstatement to
call me a video essayist
but i am a youtuber i am a content
creator
i suppose some of the stuff i do or
video essays
i suppose i am a critic
god i gotta get more comfortable with
these labels man
uh if they made a third sesame street
movie would you go see it probably not
like i've aged out of it
uh so basically doctor who version of
the prologue of kingdom hearts 2
i do not remember
like i liked kingdom hearts 2 i do not
remember a goddamn thing about the plot
i do remember that that was the one
where i started going this plot is out
of control like it was it was a little
weird in the first one second one was
like what the i'm sorry what i
definitely couldn't chart it out for you
i'm sick of watching flux reviews and
begrudgingly agreeing but still enjoying
the series
please just have at least some terrible
takes already
for you for you
well i'll i'll i'll be sure my next take
is garbage
how about how about that just for you
no i won't
uh people probably ask you this a lot
but do you have a perfect or at least
most perfect episode of doctor who
i have my favorites the thing is
i i couldn't
here's why i can't give you i feel like
a proper answer to that question because
one of the things that i love about
doctor who
is that due to the nature of the show
it can do anything and that includes
tone and themes
so
you know something like
midnight
is amazing and damn near perfect as a
contained piece of entertainment vincent
and the doctor
pretty close as well blink
uh the doctor falls these are amazing
episodes
uh the empty child and the doctor dances
my god but the thing is
they're
excellent in slightly different ways
because there is no one definitive way
to do doctor who
because like granted this is my
interpretation of your question but when
you ask me what is the perfect episode
of something that to me says what is the
episode that says this is the best that
this thing has to offer this is the
perfect iteration of what this show is
and i don't think you can do that with
doctor who because the show can be
way too
many different things
and i love that about it
so like i
think midnight is almost perfect
but it's not good in the same ways or
for the same reasons
that something like vincent and the
doctor is
you know it it
and that's
a wonderful thing about this show
so i don't really have an answer but i
enjoyed talking about why i don't have
an answer to that
is that pretentious enough for you
uh
would chris chibnall's heaven sent
uh starring 13 be too bad to watch or
too bad not to watch
can i be a snarky [ __ ] for a minute
if chip noah tr attempted to do an
equivalent to heaven sent with jody
whitaker's 13th doctor that means
he'd actually have to characterize her
and that would be the scariest thing of
all
uh
i can be a [ __ ] sometimes
do i have wolf feet slippers no i don't
have any novelty slippers i don't think
i have had
since i was like
12.
uh
for a minute oh
vacuum of comments
cheeky
uh unrelated doctor who stuff how do you
feel about the dislike count going away
it's it's an odd choice to me but i also
kind of get it
um
because
the dis in many ways the dislike
um
counter being public because like be
clear the dis the dislike counter isn't
gone it's just no longer viewable to
anyone other than the
channel operator
so
here's the thing like i do get that
um
[Music]
the the dislike was something that was
very easily abused it was something that
was used in
you know basically downvote campaigns
and the thing is much like review
bombing and the problems that have gone
on on things like metacritic and
rotten tomatoes the
uh the system being ripe for abuse means
that it has been abused increasingly
often and it's very easy to either throw
together a couple of bots or to organize
a decent enough number of people who
care about something to just go and
download the crap out of something and
then claim that that
dislike ratio proves that it's a bad
piece of content even though the only
reason it's so low
is a bunch of people organized to
deliberately drive it down so i get why
having it be public was increasingly
often just becoming a big pain in the
butt
um
so
having it just be something that the
content creators see so that it becomes
something a bit more akin to anonymous
feedback
i understand the logic that goes into
that
i kind of wish they had made it an
option
a bit like having the ability to turn
off your comments on any given video
as opposed to just making it an
automatic thing
um then again having said that i suppose
part of the issue with doing it as
something to opt in or opt out of is
everyone would always assume that if the
dislike ratio was turned the visibility
of it was turned off it's because the
creator or studio or whoever put up the
whatever knows it's crap kind of like
how many times um
there's criticism for turning off
comments even though sometimes frankly
it's warranted um so
i get why the decision was made
i'm i don't love it
um
but i i get why it's there
and like yeah you
creators still see them i saw the down
vote ratio from my village of the angels
review so yeah we still see it
so if you're wondering if we still know
that you that you don't like our
opinions oh we know
well you know
cara
hey there
good to see you have a heart
long time no see will you be ranking
flux as a series
or as individual episodes
so um
two answers to that
once it's done i'm going to do an
overview video since it is a serialized
thing i am going to talk about talk
talking about talk about it as a
completed piece once it's done at and
that'll be the saturday video after it
ends so not this coming saturday but the
one after
um
when it comes to ranking
it in terms of like doing my ranking of
um
well let me put it this way
i'll probably just toss off the ranking
of the
excuse me since there's only six
episodes i'll probably just toss
together a uh
i need to stop saying toss off because i
have enough british viewers and to say
that somebody tossed off is means
something very very different over there
but i i might toss together just a quick
uh you know this is the order i put them
in when i do that video
um and
and in that case it'll be individual
episodes when and if i ever do a ranking
that would
um necessitate looking at them
like if i'm doing a themed ranking or
if i ever do ranking the entire modern
series again with this new stuff
integrated into it which wouldn't be
something i would do until further down
the line or honestly i probably won't do
it until i've seen enough of classic to
be able to integrate classic into that
and make a stupidly long video
um but
anyway
um
the i will probably
i will probably deal with these
individually because while
um certainly
uh the first the third and the fifth
ones so that's halloween apocalypse once
upon time and
uh survivors of the flocks are
definitely not standalone stories they
also aren't really like
first or second half of two parters in a
way that i would be comfortable saying
this is just another part of the same
story and
war of the centaurus and village of the
angels are are disconnected enough
that i just feel like i would want to
deal with those different like it messes
up my normal system that's the short
version it screws it screws up my normal
system
there we go
uh strum dynasty
thank you very much have yourself a
heart
to me timeless child issue isn't canon
it undermines the dock running away from
cal from gallifrey it was so relatable
now it's an old repeated intentional
scheme
like
not that specifically but the idea of
undermining
um
the nature of
the doctor
and undermining who the doctor is that
is my big problem because i'm not a lore
hound i like
i could care less about lore
more often than not i care some about
lore but
i care more about stories than i care
about lore
because it's not the same thing
but yeah i hate what the timeless child
did to the importance of the doctor as a
character that's not a lore thing that
is
to my mind the doctor should not matter
on the universal scale
they shouldn't but they do now and that
never seems to be going away anymore
jeffrey
thank you so much
have a heart
how would how would you think a
crossover between doctor who and
resident
evil how would joe
uh barry burn and chris redfield there
against the doctor go
um
i don't know resident evil well enough
to actually engage in that thought
exercise i have
the only resident evil game i've played
at all was resident evil 4 and i only
played that for about an hour
like
17 years ago
or so roundabout
it's uh
it's been a while
uh so
and none of the characters you listed
are from are from resident evil 4. um
so i i don't really have like i'm more
familiar with the resident evil movies
the ones with mila jovovich than i am
with the video games
so lose myself some more nerd cred there
which also means yes i i i never played
the um the resident evil with um with
big vampire or mommy milkies
uh in your last stream you spoke for a
moment which i think should have been
uploaded as his own clip i'm surprised i
couldn't find it where is it all right
if i upload it myself
as long as you link back to the full
thing yeah sure go ahead
what are were your thoughts on the
hashtag give elsa a girlfriend um
i don't have a problem with things like
that becoming hashtag campaigns like
they did the same thing with uh with
give cap a boyfriend
um
i just i just always question anybody
don't
don't sink too much emotional commitment
into this idea
because
odds are they're gonna do their own
thing whether it is this or something
else um but i don't i don't think it's a
bad idea to make your desires known to
the creators and i feel like um provided
you don't abuse it uh and like attach it
to negative comments but a hashtag
campaign is a good way to show a
groundswell of support for an idea
um without having to like harass
individuals about it
which you know you shouldn't be doing
hey
what would you think if um
13 dies mid battle and they have the new
doctor take over mid-battle as the as a
fresh regeneration concept
um
i think that's a hard sell
because at this point it's the kind of
thing that could have been pulled off
during the classic series at this point
there is an expected momentousness there
is an expected level of
um
just awe
in a doctor's departure
and to
skim over that in the middle of an
action scene
is
kind of neat on paper but i think
ultimately he's going to leave a lot of
people feeling like
that particular doctor didn't get the
send-off they deserved
i don't think it would be impossible to
pull off i'm just saying that would be
that would be the trick to try and deal
with
connor mitchell
thank you for the super chat i
appreciate it very very much
are you disappointed with doctor who
flux so far yes
i can i think i can confidently say that
well no i'll backtrack um
i am mildly disappointed because my
expectations were not
super high
just
because
i've said this before all the best stuff
during whittaker's era
hasn't been written by chipnel so going
to this knowing he was basically writing
the whole thing himself
um
[Music]
i
i didn't have high expectations
you know what would be cool a gay uh
disney prince movie
that'd be cool like they'll get to it
one of these days
they'll test run it on disney plus and
then they'll actually do it i don't know
five years from now
would you say this past episode was
better than previous flex episodes
no
no i would only say the way in which i
didn't like it no longer surprised me so
the blow was softer
like
the halloween apocalypse was very
frustrating for me because i didn't yet
know what i was dealing with and seeing
all these
story lines pile up and thinking to
myself how in the heck is this gonna
work it just made me nervous and it made
me think this is a even if this gets
pulled together later this is a rough
way to start a serialized story
and i feel like nobody was on my page
with that first episode
when the
and then when the third one came along
the only reason i still had some hope
that maybe it would be pulled together
was i i had really liked the second
episode i had really liked war of the
santarans so
that i kind of get my got getting
gotten my hopes back up a little bit but
then by the time
um
the survivors of the flux happened this
most recent episode the pattern had been
set in already and so i
i feel like i already knew the exact
ways in which i was gonna not like it
so
i was certainly softer on it and so far
as i didn't get nearly as worked up
but that's not because it was any better
it's just because i was used to the way
that it wasn't working for me
strum dynasty again thank you
thank you thank you thank you
going off that can we
acknowledge disney's cowardice with lead
lgbt characters if they can't censor it
easily they won't they
uh don't do it usually
i mean
you're not wrong but at the same time i
don't get on
disney's case about that as much as
other people because
neither is anybody else
i mean it's it's easy to pick on disney
because disney is you know they they
control so much of both
um you know the biggest mainstream
entertainment right now and also like
the media of our childhoods and so those
of us who are
allies really want them to you know take
the step
but like
warner brothers mass family
entertainment is not
doing much better
and
you know it's not like dreamworks
has done it either so you know
you're not wrong but i don't think
singling out disney being like disney
should do better like if
[ __ ] everybody should do better
that's kind of where i'm at any advice
for writing an evil king nope
nope i have no advice whatsoever because
i i do not
there are certain things you shouldn't
ask me how to write
because i have no interest in writing
them
so when i wrote my novel
i had um an i had i had three
rules of things that i absolutely would
not do
no prophecies or chosen ones
no
great evil or rising darkness or
singular villain of the world which i
feel like an evil king kind of is
uh and no romantic subplot for the
league character
so i'm a bad person to ask for advice on
any one of those three things because i
don't i go out of my way to not ever
write them what about loose and amity
and owl house okay so a couple things
about that first of all uh the show is
getting cut short and it's not even
getting a third proper season so yeah
they did it and then pulled the plug
shortly after so
um
um
but the other thing is generally when we
talk about this tv and movies are it's
funny the video i shot today which is
going up on saturday i bring this up
so
the status of television and i would
lump streaming in with this is usually a
bit ahead of movies because for
television and streaming
they need so many hours of product
that they're not going to be as rigorous
about policing exactly what it is plus
it's made at a much lower price point
per product than film is there's more of
it and it's made cheaper so they always
take this isn't just disney
as a medium television always takes more
risks
sooner than movies do
but the thing is especially at this
point in time because media is so
subdivided and so niche and so to the
point that like something can be a
massive hit with a specific niche
audience and the mainstream audience
might never even know that show exists
it's not like when i was growing up and
there were only
four main channels and then if you
if you were upper middle class you had
cable
so it's not like that anymore whereas
before whatever went on the main
channels the broadcast networks of tv
everyone would know about now it's this
tiny little niche thing
buried in the algorithm of a streaming
platform and they can do
more risky stuff because it's not going
to get noticed by as many people whereas
film
is still like especially if you're
talking anything made by disney or the
really bigger companies
is still intended to be seen by as many
people in the mainstream as possible
fewer of them get made a year and they
want everybody to pile into the theater
to watch these same things so film is
always slower
than television is
thank you very much uh work
war game word game plays
that's what i'm going with uh
thank you for being you you're welcome
heart to the ruth doctor um ruth doctor
equals series 6b
um i'm more comfortable with that than a
lot of the other possible answers that i
suppose anyone who's watching who
doesn't know the season 6b theory so
this is a fan theory that came up
because of
the episode during the sixth doctor's
era called the two doctors where the
second dr patrick trout appeared now
there was a lot of weirdness at the
front end of that
um where
they uh basically the time lords pulled
the second doctor and jamie out of their
timeline to like do stuff for them which
doesn't make any sense because the
second doctor was still on the run from
the time lords so the idea of the time
lords working for him and them just
letting him go at the end of it doesn't
make a lot of sense
especially with what we knew so this
created the season six b theory that
states that between seasons six and
seven uh of the original classic series
was when trouton was working with and
for the time lords until doing something
that pissed them off and put him back on
the run again but it's a it's a
speculative season that we never saw
now as somebody noted in the chat i
missed oh vacuum of comments uh it
there is nothing at this point to
support the idea that she is
um from season six b
uh the initial issue with that would
have been there weren't enough
regenerations obviously that's not the
case anymore with the timeless child but
right now
most things indicate that she is a
pre-heart and over generation that
having been said not having gone back
and re-watched
series 12 yet
it may be possible to slot her in or at
least it may not be that much more work
to slaughter in there than to slaughter
in pre-heart no it just depends on what
questions
uh chibnall feels like answering or
ignoring
uh it'll go one of the two ways
thank you very much rob chalice
do you think you'll enjoy
rtd 2 and any predictions
i had to read that several times before
i said it out loud because my brain
wanted to change that to r2d2 i'm like
did is r2d2 getting a series did i miss
something like no so uh
russell d
davies in his second run i have no
predictions i have no idea what he's
gonna do
um
do i think i'll enjoy it
i hope i will enjoy it
i think
odds are
that i will like it more than i have
liked
chibnall's run
that isn't the world's highest bar to
clear
so but that's that's kind of all i got i
i'll put it this way while i have my
reservations about bringing back an
older showrunner which i've talked about
previously
i do
i i am more interested to see what he
will do than the idea of chibnall having
stayed on longer
i i can't argue otherwise
oh
another super chat they're coming
quick tonight defunct
hey hey recent subscriber thank you
i love your work have you seen any of
the new chucky series and if so what are
your thoughts on queer rep in it i have
not the only bit of it i've seen
was the bit that i clipped
for uh the video i did on my vera wild
channel talking about all the nonsense
over at the bbc
uh and lily kade
that one clip
of chucky
talking about his kid from the most
maligned film in the series so the fact
that they were willing to acknowledge
the film the least people like
and have chuckie go i got a kid
you have a kid
gender fluid and you're okay with that
i'm not a monster jake
like the serial killer doll powered by a
fake understanding of voodoo
is
is more progressive than the goddamn bbc
like that on principle i kind of love i
haven't seen the series um because i
don't i don't have the i don't have what
it's on
um so
have you talked about why you dislike
prophecies if not would you mind saying
a little about it
okay
let's see how coherently i can throw
this together
so i don't know i might have done an
author's diary
a while back
um
about why i don't like prophecies
but
here's the main thing i feel like they
limit what the story can be
the instant you introduce a prophecy
by its nature almost regardless of how
it's dealt with there are now only two
options
the prophecy happens
or it doesn't now you could make an
argument that well most story setups
there's two there's only two options
like
will the heroes beat the villain or
won't they and yes that's true but the
prophecy makes some makes it much more
specific
so the prophecies usually deal with this
specific person
will kill the villain or they won't if
it's trying to be subversive about it
but the idea of how will this team beat
the villain who will be the one to take
them on you know how and
a lot of these prophecies will even
answer how
it'll happen
and it just removes so many
possibilities for me that's my first
frustration with it my other frustration
with it is not inherent to the trope
but it's in
most examples of prophecies that i can
think of to some degree which is that it
uses prophecy as an excuse to not tell a
story properly what i mean by that is
these writers or these shows or whatever
will do something with the story or have
the characters head in a certain
direction or the story like twist in
this weird coincidence like what and
instead of exploring that or explaining
it or justifying why the characters
would do this the narrative just kind of
goes nope it's prophecy that was fate
no that's lazy that's what that is it's
very very easy
for prophecy to become a crutch
and i especially hate it as a late
introduction to something
it's
one thing if something presents prophecy
right out the gate
and is making clear like this is what
we're dealing with but i hate it i hate
it i hate it
so much when i'm halfway through a movie
or halfway through a season of
television or freaking lord forbid in a
later season season on the television
show and somebody goes there's a
prophecy oh
shut up
and like not to mention the fact that
there's always this assumed authority of
the prophecy
you found a piece of paper that said a
thing oh it's a prophecy no it's a piece
of paper that said a thing
but narrative gives it all this weight
like it's momentous and it's meaningful
it doesn't have to be there's no reason
for it to be there i find it much more
interesting to justify what characters
will do and justify choices they will
make and justify within character and
story how it goes rather than going
that's how it was faded to happen
bite me
there we go
john vinyls thank you very much for the
super chat i appreciate that fun fact
creator of child's play and chucky don
mancini is a gay man i did not know that
about don mancini
very cool
oh
could a character play by a puppet work
on star trek
um
i just i'm not sure they've built a like
there's just way too much star trek then
they've set the standard for what aliens
are i'm not saying couldn't work but
like
you kind of need to introduce that a lot
earlier
how does prophecy overlap with or
compared to closed time loops or
bootstraps well okay so when you're
talking time loops and paradoxes that's
a bit like what i said where where the
prophecy is up front and
you're making clear this is what this is
about
it's when prophecy gets introduced into
a story that doesn't need it and could
is fully capable of move of moving
forward
without it that's where i hate seeing
prophecy i actually like time loops
they're really hard to do correctly
um
but
i uh
i i i feel like
a st like let me put it this way i did
start writing something that that
has a prophecy is an element
but it's a joke
um but i also introduced that very very
very early into the thing um
it's a
it's a story idea that i might get back
to one of these days yes i will check
thank you heroine thank you very much i
will check the discord in just a moment
i have to finish the thought or i'll
lose it
um
so
i might get back to the story it's
called you are not the chosen one so
like again if you lay it out right at
the start but again i feel like way too
many times
prophecy gets introduced
midway through a story
discovered either by the villain
um or sometimes it's like what drives
the villain like that's another one the
self-fulfilling prophecy used to be a
subversion and now it's really dumb
where like the
prophecy
is something the villain finds out like
oh this person will defeat me so i must
stop them now and then you broke them in
and they don't even care about you
except you like all that it's all played
out there were places to go at some
point
but there isn't any more
all right i gotta check the discord
excuse me let's see what we got here a
reminder the council of geeks discord is
a patreon exclusive perk so if you feel
like going to patreon.com council of
geeks and signing up there at a two
dollar or higher tier you too can get
access to the discord which not only
guarantees that i will read your
question without having to do a super
chat it has tons of channels for
everything from doctor who to star wars
to superheroes to gaming
writing
music listening et cetera et cetera it's
a nice chill place have wonderful mods
and
please join us there there i i can like
i can do a sales pitch
i don't do it often but i can
okay
um probably not coming because i'm still
behind on doctor who okay yeah if you're
wanting to avoid spoilers probably
better to skip it
um won't be staying so question in your
survivors of the flux review you
mentioned shows that had surprised you
by pulling off something you did not
think they could what were some of them
and why so like i know there's more than
this but my current go-to example
was and i have because i have the
receipts to show that i did not think
this was gonna work
i did not think that season five of
shear on the princess of power was going
to able be able to successfully redeem
the character of catra
i didn't i i suspected they were going
to try and i did not think they were
going to be able to pull it off
um i did outline what i think they
should do if they were going to try they
did not do that they did something
completely different and it absolutely
works so like that's that's the off of
my top of my head example i know there's
other ones though i know there's
definitely others but that's that's sort
of the one that comes to mind because
again like you can actually look through
my own old videos and see where i
thought it wasn't gonna work
do you feel there could have been a
better way to discourage dislike bombs
like have an account watch a certain
amount of videos before unlocking the
ratings or something especially since i
feel like it doesn't do much to curb
harassment since it's just going to spew
into the comments this is coming from
someone who disliked
uh bomb who was dislike bombed at least
three times okay so this is the just the
turning off of the dislikes
thing again um
honestly
what i would have said was
i
i'm curious as to why youtube felt it
still needed the data at all like it's
obviously still counting them because
for the algorithm somewhere
um except that we know historically that
dislikes don't actually discourage it in
the algorithm it all counts as
engagement
so
like at this point i'm actually starting
to wonder if the like dislike feature is
just becoming superfluous in and of
itself
um since they just went ahead and gutted
half of it
does the other half serve as much
purpose now i don't even know
also as someone who has been the target
of a harassment campaign yeah i'm a
little bit annoyed when people bring up
just like bomb so yeah personal
experience is god in my judgment sorry
yeah i mean you're not wrong that it
won't
um discourage
harassing behavior but again it's kind
of like what i said about the
um
about the hate mail thing
if you make it a little bit harder fewer
people will do it so i think you would
you there were more people using the
dislike bombing than were hitting up the
comments and anyone who's willing to put
in the effort to hit up the comments was
either skipping the dislike bomb or or
was doing both anyway and i don't think
it's going to change their behavior and
i don't think people who were just
hitting the dislike but weren't
harassing people in the comments are
suddenly going to put in the extra
effort to do that
so
i'll i'll agree it's not going to curb
harassment but i think neither keeping
it nor ditching it is really going to
impact that either way it's just a very
specific form of things that like i kind
of get why they got rid of it but now
i'm wondering why they why they have
left behind the half that they have
um
and one last one self-fulfilling
prophecies aren't a subversion they're a
default greek mythology ran on
self-fulfilling prophecies yes that's
true i mean and that like and that's the
last one so that that was kind of like
the only way that
prophecy stories tried to be
cute is like ooh but the way the
prophecy is fulfilled is quite the way
that you thought it would except that if
this is not your first rodeo
you are probably looking at that
prophecy and thinking okay what are all
the possible ways this could get
fulfilled besides the obvious one
because it's rarely fulfilled the
obvious way anymore so even trying to be
subversive or clever about it is it's
it's increasingly difficult and i just
don't think it's a good i just i don't
i don't know what writers think they
gain other than a crutch and i'm never
going to encourage writers to use a
crutch
that's not to say you're automatically
bad for using it
that's fine but it's why i'm
like i don't like seeing them
uh any advice on writing gods
be careful about writing real ones and
when i say real ones i mean ones that
people actually uh worship or any that
are equivalents and very clear parallels
to ones that are still actively
worshipped be careful and respectful
about that that is the only advice i'm
going to give
joseph rakes thank you very much
uh for the super chat good evening long
time watcher love the vids just curious
if you watch the uh he-man revelations
part two i think it's fun i did i also
shot a review of that i want to try and
edit that tomorrow and have that up in
the break room
um then i need to try
i need to try and finish watching
[Music]
the cowboy bebop
live action
oh god
it's so bad
i'm trying
so hard
so so so so hard to give it the benefit
of the doubt and not just crap all over
it
but it's so bad
it's so bad you guys like oh
i know i need to get out of the habit of
saying guys because i know that's a
gendered term but it's still like i've
i've had i've had a glass of water and
so like my brain's defaulting to default
settings but it's just
so bad
ah and i say that who doesn't even hold
up the um
the original as this god tier level
anime like a lot of people do
i think it's overrated but holy cow
why is vicious a love struck villain
vicious was never good
but i will take boring original flavor
vicious over this
and suffer but like they tried to give
him a personality and they gave him an
insufferable one
he was never good and now he's horrible
and they've ruined julia
like
the fact that
the fact that they even gave julia a
character is kind of self-defeating
because the point is not who she was as
a person the point is what she meant to
spike she functions much better as that
as being someone who is referred to but
we don't really know because we don't
really know her but we know what
her
being in his life did to spike that's
what matters so focusing on her and
giving her an insanely generic
you know sort of abused girlfriend of a
freaking
mobster personality and storyline huh i
gotta get out of here like oh my god you
are so boring
the version of you that like we saw in
only like two episodes and you barely
said five sentences worked way better
than whatever the f freaking hell this
is
i'm only four episodes into it
but it's terrible it's so bad
so bad
ah
do i think onward ryan the last dragon
and kanto will get their own tv series i
haven't seen encanto
uh
ryan the last dragon could support one
that world would support it not onward i
found the world to be by far the least
interesting thing
about onward it wasn't even close i they
would have thought it was a
thoroughly unexplored concept in terms
of the
world can we make dudes a gender-neutral
term i tend to use it as one
um i am still trying to break that habit
though
uh who would you like to see right
uh for 13 from previous teams
i don't
off the top of my head
um i don't have an easy answer to that
i'm not going to come up with one before
i wrap up the stream
viciously is basically discount
sephiroth well yes
he was always a suffer off knockoff like
here's the thing
vicious is bad
in both versions of cowboy bebop but
he's bad for different reasons he's bad
in the original because he feels like
what you would get if you plugged a ton
of anime cliches and tropes into an
algorithm and told it to create for you
an all-purpose anime villain that you
could slot into any anime ever made
that's what vicious feels like in the
original he does not
fit or feel
properly integrated into the thing he's
like he is such a placeholder of a
villain
and he's the only record like there are
legit good villains in that show and
he's the only recurring one
but then in the show he's just this
this
simpering
little annoying
like
weird expression slightly bug-eyed
i don't even know what they're going for
but i hate him
oh yeah
the alternative you guys is y'all
like y'all is very useful as a
gender-neutral collective
oh
thank thank you carolyn john vinyls i
forgot to give you a heart
there we go thank you carolyn thank you
very much um
but yeah the the thing about y'all is in
my head it's a southern term and
i'd like i can't even think y'all
it's not a phrase that
flows through my brain any advice on
writing fictitious gods original ones um
uh
not really
because
there are many different ways to write
them since you're saying god's plural
i'm assuming you are dealing with a
pantheon and a polyistic uh sorry not
polytheistic
uh arrangement
in which case like
write them however you want now most
pantheons deal with
frankly petty gods um because when you
have that many and not any one of them
is in control of everything they're
going to be very protective of their
little sliver of power so writing them
as sort of petty tyrants would be the
default but the thing is
like just shift the personality
depending on what it is they are the god
of
just have fun with it
i kind of want the grand serpent to team
up with jack robertson and then betray
him just for an absolutely perfect joke
reference related to why you hated
robertson to begin with
like what the hell what is the why
why does the grand serpent have a plot
line
why
like here's the thing the only thing
that i can come up with
is that um
the doctor made a reference to with the
flux happening you know people could
take advantage and maybe that's what
they're trying to do with him except
that honestly that's the kind of thing
that would be really well suited to one
of the specials and like have the
timeline largely run in parallel with
the events of flux until it meets up
with the doctor on the taillight who has
to who is still cleaning up the pieces
after sorting out however the heck
they're gonna sort it out to inject that
in the not even the middle and the tail
end of a story that's supposed to be
wrapping up
why
ah thank the deep south for y'all the
best gender-neutral collective pronoun
it is a really good one for that
it is
okay
i am going to wrap it up um
thank you all
for
joining me thank you for watching thank
you for the super chats thank you for
the company
and i hope that you all
take care
i think just with the time difference
some of you are already into december
if you celebrate any notable holiday in
december i hope you have got your
shopping already done i need to do that
yep yes i do um but i hope you take care
and i hope that you remember that
you are beautiful
you are valid
and you are loved
you are the council
i just run the meetings and until next
time this council
is adjourned
my cavity